un jour de plus au compteur pour mohamed
canda caire cela fait sept ans déjà
qu'il trimballe son taxi sur le bitume
de new york
mohamed vient du bangladesh il a atterri
six ans 83 pour éduquer ses trois
enfants
il est passé par tous les jobs le 11
septembre 2001 il se rendait à son
travail
il était manager d'un restaurant situé à
100 mètres du world trade center
je me suis senti très mal parce que
c'était là où je travaillais joyau
diriger vers wall street quand le
premier avion a frappé la tour j'étais
exactement là j'ai tout vu j'ai beaucoup
pleuré parce que vous savez c'était
comment vous dire mohamed ne trouve pas
les mots ce jour qui a changé la face du
monde a aussi entaché sa foi comme près
de 700000 new yorkais il est musulman
c'est là qu'était le world trade center
regardez le chantier est en cours guan 0
c'est le point de fixation de la haine
contre sa religion
neuf ans après les attentats la plaie
reste béante les tensions sont ravivées
par un projet de centre culturel
islamique à deux pas des lieux du drame
c'est juste la main doivent construire
la mosquée ici devrait voir le jour un
bâtiment futuriste de 15 étages
comprenant une mosquée un projet qui
divise l'amérique entière à la fin de
l'été opposants et partisans
s'affrontaient dans la rue la polémique
a fait le tour du monde
c'est un centre islamique mais tout le
monde sera le bienvenu pour mieux
connaître l'islam
pourtant l'étude amalgames entre islam
et terrorisme
il pense qu'on est tous des terroristes
donc la mosquée est un lieu on apprend
le terrorisme est de 15 mais c'est faux
aussi c'est trop
plus encore aujourd'hui qu'hier mohamed
se méfie des amalgames 20 heures il est
temps de faire une pause pour aller
prier et ce n'est qu'à quelques mètres
seulement de la mosquée qu'il enfile son
coût fit son couvre chef religieux
je ne veux pas montrer que je suis
musulman sait jamais à qui on a affaire
on ne sait jamais vous savez c'est pour
ma sécurité
à l'angle de la 29e et broadway les
carlingues jaune garnissent le bitume
il n'y a qu'au tour de cette mosquée que
les taxis peuvent se garer et 50% des
chauffeurs new yorkais sont musulmans
c'est la quatrième prière de la journée
mouais mais travaillera encore quatre ou
cinq heures avant de rentrer chez lui
brooklyn sud est de manhattan
un district grand comme deux fois paris
au coeur duquel se trouve un petit bout
de bangladesh les 200000 bengladeshi de
new york viennent y respirer un peu de
l'air du pays
c'est à deux pas d'ici que vie mohamed
avec sa femme et ses trois enfants canda
caire ça veut dire grand coeur pour lui
et ses proches
ils travaillent plus de 60 heures par
semaine c'est pour ça qu'on est ici dans
ce pays c'est pour gagner de l'argent et
l'envoyer à la famille là-bas au
bangladesh
éduquer nos enfants c'est la survie on
fait ce qu'on peut
les enfants de mohamed n'ont jamais mis
les pieds au bangladesh
ils sont new yorkais mais depuis 2001
leurs parents redoutent qu on les traite
en d'étrangers après le 11 septembre le
rejet de l'islam est devenu un réel
motif d'inquiétude pour nous parfois il
ya des gens qui font des remarques
dégueulasse mais moi ça m'importe peu je
me fiche de leurs opinions
je sais qui je suis je connais ma foi et
j'en suis fier on a été pris pour cible
sur tellement de sujets on est vraiment
préoccupé par ça j'espère qu'avec le
temps ça va changer
j'espère vraiment
la famille de mohamed est inquiète
depuis peu taxi musulman à new york est
devenu un métier à risque il y a quatre
mois un conducteur bengladeshi du nom
d'ahmed sharif s'est fait poignardé en
plein service le client un photographe
militaire de 21 ans a agi au seul motif
que son chauffeur était musulman il a
failli perdre la vie
l'homme qui était à son chevet à
l'hôpital c'est lui mohamed type ou
sultan et bengladeshi est membre d'un
des principaux syndicats de taxis new
yorkais avec cette agression l affaire
de la mosquée dans tous les médias on
parle d' islamophobie
ça me met vraiment mal à l'aise résultat
c'est toute une profession qui
s'enferment dans le mutisme depuis
l'agression d'un match live il a été
conseillé aux chauffeurs de taxi de ne
pas parler de l'islam ni de leur foi m
je la ferme à partir de 10h du soir six
dernières années je ne l'affirmé pas je
parler aux gens je suis new-yorkais
j'adore ce pays j'adore cette ville
j'aime discuter avec les clients
mais maintenant c'est plus possible
20 heures à la mosquée la dernière
prière s'achève no2 mohamed s'y croisent
régulièrement ont pris tous ensemble on
est tous bangladeshis et en plus on est
tous voisins à brooklyn le parvis de la
mosquée est l'un des rares lieux des
changes ces temps ci les visages sont
plus tendus que d'habitude
[Musique]
l'agression ben ahmed charif pourrait
très bien se reproduire cela arrivera si
l'administration les médias les
politiques ne changent pas leurs
mentalités vis-à-vis de l'islamophobie
aux états unis la montée de
l'islamophobie est une réalité même à
new york ville la plus cosmopolite du
pays selon les sondages 46% des
américains pensent que l'islam encourage
la violence plus que les autres
religions